[Musique]
au couteau - quand tu étais au pays de
rien à dire on dit que les petits
cadeaux entretiennent l'amitié mais ça
dépend des cadeaux sa chute à triumph et
la salle éclata en applaudissements
ado ado ado ratio 16 à voile ou en
suis-je encore cette somme s elle me
trouve l'esprit cette montre est devenue
folle
elles sont tout le temps ça me dérange
et je ne peux pas écrire des déboires
cobras débarrasser elle est très belle
très rare mais trop brouillons entre m e
mail car je vous deja 1 sans doute hors
bourse car pas du tout soit c'est le
brave du je vais vous dire que le grand
yaka n'a pas besoin de jouer aujourd'hui
colboc douloureuse et pour vous en
regard cela je vous offre cette votre
pro de la gens vous ont repris c'est
trop c'est trop
elle est magnifique salle sa ville
sonnent de temps en temps pour passer le
temps merci je suis ravi merci merci je
vais ainsi un petit bar temps pour
réfrigérateurs ça donne ça suffit ça
suffit à petit ma barque de repos me
fera du bien
mais cette montre ça s'arrête silas
paillot sillage il ne faut plus à des
sepra be
cette montre est infernal sa sonnerie va
me faire repérer il faut que je batte
débarrasse je crois bien que je suis en
retard et le grand et enfin m'attend oui
titus tuer sans retard si tu avais eu
deux bombes tuent serait toujours à
l'heure
trois raisons mostra mais je n'ai pas de
montre alors leurs proches celle ci je
te l'offre de me la donnes ta montre aux
mauves corps et elles sont et chadi
proches a dit pan et coûtera elle sonne
vienne dont ruby un chat lui arrive de
temps je me tords merci mosca pu me fait
un très beau cadeau en rangée et sois
tranquille
elle ne me quittera sa mère je l'espère
bien
elle appelle à présent il faut te taire
nous allons c'est le grand iata nous
sommes tout le temps le grand est
atteint voudra s'emparer de toi
les sétois donc qu'il nous casse les
oreilles tu as bien compris tu ne faudra
plus dit fait montrer trop bavarde
il faut que je m'en débarrasse
rapidement elle me rend fou cette montre
comment m'en débarrasser enfin c'est
pitié pour mes oreilles conduisait mois
devant le grand yaka et tu vois
l'institut ce qu'est un retard toujours
un retard tuera tous à coups de bâtons
oui grand garage je suis en retard mais
c'est pour vous faire plaisir
c'est pour me faire plaisir que tu me
fais attar titus tu te moques de moi oui
dans iata mon grand il ya ka set à cause
de la montre que vous apporte
l'un des grands ya pas et on vole une
montre qui sonne
oh comme c'est joli elle est pour moi à
titus est moindre elle est pour vous
grand yaka et vous savez elles sont en
aura toujours
et les verts et elle est belle comme moi
mais moi je ne sors pas si tu veux la
donner
oui grand yaka et je suis bien content
de vous la donner
dieu seul est plus besoin de toi à titus
tu peux aller ailleurs elle sonne je
l'aï eu je vais l'écouter jusqu'à ce
soir
ouf nous voilà tranquille plus de fonds
nettes et plus de rang atteint et après
après c'est une autre histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]